(飲み物を飲む音)
暑い！！！
暑い暑い暑い暑い暑い！！！アァァァァァァ！！！
やべっ２２歳だった
あっついんだよ
こんな暑い中お前達は何を食べるか？
俺は知っている。アイスクリームだ。
そう！暑い日はやはりアイスクリームが食べたくなるわけなんだけども
オレが今日買ってきたやつはこちらです
ガリガリ君ソーダ味
まあ
こちらのガリガリ君ソーダ味があるんだけども
お前たち知ってた通りなんだけど
アイスクリームっていうのは
一回食っちゃうと、すぐ食べっちゃて
こうペロペロペロっていっちゃってすぐ食べちゃう
早い時は一分足らずでもうアイスクリームを食べちゃうっていう
そのアイスのおいしい至福の時間っていうのは
たったの一分しか続かない、とても
短い時間を楽しむ、とてもコンスタントな遊びなんだよ。
俺はそれでアイスクリームは短い時間で楽しむってことはとても悲しいことだと俺は思ってる。
もっとアイスクリームを食べることによって、アイスクリームのよさを長い時間楽しめるように、こう、
テンポラリーな味の感覚ではなくもっとコンスタンティングに広がっていくような味の感覚をアイスクリームで楽しみたいと俺は思ってるわけなんだけど、
そうするためにはガリガリ君ソーダ味っていうのはやっぱり氷菓菓子だからすぐ食べてすぐ無くなっちゃうんだよ。
そういうのは長持ちしないから、もっとこう、長い時間を楽しむために僕はあることに@;")%#*<~った。
なんて言ってる俺？
だけど…僕が言いたいのはアイスクリームは…あ、危ない
アイスクリームっつうのはなぁ
やっぱ溶ける物だから、すぐ！…食べちゃう
とても短いんですけどもぉ
俺は今日天才的な事を考えた
もっとおまえらがアイスクリームを長い時間楽しめる為に
こうは！
こうはじゃねぇわ…
今日はこちらのガリガリ君ソーダ味を（３度目）
あれが（俺が）
一滴ずつね食べていこうと思います
外で
ベランダがあるんで外で一滴ずつ食べていくんですけども
まぁ普通に食べると短時間で食べ終わる
アイスクリームをどれだけ どれだけ
長い時間楽しめるかってのをねちょっと
実際に検証してみようと思います　いくぞっ！
ここにこう紐をね
上から吊るして
ここにガリガリ君をおく
ちょ 今作るわ
はい、こんな感じです
こんな感じでここに
ガリガリ君を
ガリガリ君をここに置きます
あ、もう始まったじゃん　始まった始まった
もうすぐスタートです
もう始まる始まる
タイマーどうしよ ×２
タイマータイマーここでいい　もうスタートスタート
もうスタートしてる(焦り)
12時お昼の12時からスタートです
もうスタートしてる。おいおい待て待て
大丈夫か？OKな？
よしっ、やるぞ
もう始まってるなぁ
あ、うめえわ。
これ待って、
♪～
（時計が落ちる音）
ええっ～
ええっ～、時計時計時計
（時計の電池をはめ直す音）
（風でヒモが揺れる音）
♪～
（水滴を飲みこむ音）
おいおいっ！
（風でヒモが揺れる音）
あっ
やばいやばい
♪～
あっ取れた。
わあっ、風、風・・・
風が強い・・・
もうマジでね、ラストのほうだと思うんですけども、
少なくなればなるほど、
出てくるスピードが遅く、あっ
（水滴を吸う）　なるんですよね。
（風でヒモが揺れる音）
うわあっ、あっ。はい、
（拍手）
ちゃんと全部なくなりましたー。
はい。という訳で、今回の実験で分かったことはですね、
ぜひそこの暇な人とかね、
時間がある人はぜひ、やってみたらいいと思います。
僕は二度とやりません。ばいちゃ！
完
（エンディング）